the man police say stole six atm
machines from businesses all across town
is behind bars right now good afternoon
thanks for joining us at four on this
friday i'm kirsten joyce and i'm
christian casadas 42 year old scott west
is facing more than 30 charges including
destruction of property and burglary joe
moeller joins us live now from one of
those businesses near the 215 in south
rainbow with how police tied him to the
crimes joe
the video of these crimes went viral
scott west is accused of pulling his
truck upright here up to this window
tying
his truck up to the atm that's right
inside that window and pulling it and
then driving off the business owners we
spoke to say they're happy to know
someone is now behind bars
[Music]
this is video from body spa salons and
wellness police say this is one of six
shops where scott west stole atms like
this causing a lot of damage the front
of the shop was torn apart erica so
works here and says it was an
inconvenience and cost thousands of
dollars it's kind of scary right because
you know we don't know who can be in
here at any time i'm glad they caught
him but yeah
i mean it's good news right that he's
caught this barbershop ernesto is near
eastern entropicana was also hit the
store owner is glad to hear of an arrest
as he was forced to close for half a
month for the repairs you can see he
pulled the atm out police found and
connected the truck west was in and say
he admitted details of the crimes when
he was questioned after his arrest on
february 10th his reason for the crimes
money to pay bills
now back out here live the employees and
owners that i spoke to say they have not
replaced the atm inside of the shops
just yet and they don't even know if
they want them after what happened
reporting live in the southwest valley
joe mohler live local now